[Musik]
ja bereits fast ein halbes jahr krieg in
der ukraine und hort heute wollen wir
uns ansehen die militärische lage im
land dazu wollen wir uns drei regionen
ansehen wo gerade besonders toll
gekämpft wird nämlich einmal hier im
nordosten des landes in der region aktiv
einmal hier in der region donetsk wonach
der eroberung von gesamt lohans durch
die russische armee jetzt die grenze die
die kämpfe toben und am ende wollen
jetzt auch noch im süden des landes
ansehen auch dort versucht die russische
armee vorzubringen in der region person
als allererstes bilder aus die uns noch
mal zeigen was für ein vernichtungskrieg
die russische armee hier
vom stapel gebrochen hat hier die stadt
wäre es tobe eine grenzstadt eine front-
statt die noch von der ukraine gehalten
oder aber wir sehen es steht kein
einziges haus mehr kein einziges haus
ist mehr bewohnbar jedes haus wurde
zerstört hunderte häuser hier
vernichtete seinen drohen aufnahme die
die ukrainische armee gestern
veröffentlicht hat wir gucken uns das
einfach mal an es ist also es sieht
wirklich aus wie in deutschland nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg wenn man so will alles
zerstört kein einziges dach existiert
mehr 2800 menschen haben in paris sowie
gelebt kein mensch ist mir da einige
ukrainische soldaten wohnen noch wo kann
man fast sagen noch in den trümmern und
werden tagtäglich von der russischen
armee beschossen dass also die taktik
mit der die russische mir vorgeht nicht
etwa gezielte schläge sondern alles
komplett vernichten und wenn dann nichts
mehr ist wenn da kein mensch mehr leben
kann wenn da kein ukrainischer soldaten
sich mehr bewegen kann oder verstecken
kann dann nimmt man diese städte ein so
also die aktuelle taktik russland mit
massiver feuerkraft im osten des landes
ja was macht die ukraine dagegen sie
versucht sich zu wehren vor allem mit
westlichen waffen und hier hat die
westliche waffe die heimat der
amerikaner ein ganz besonderes ziel
zerstört nämlich einen folterkeller ein
folterzentrum der russen dieses haus in
der stadt per verweis in einem hochhaus
in der stadt per verweist wurde von der
russischen armee benutzt monatelang als
hauptquartier und und das war das
besondere im märz wurden hier sieben
ukrainische soldaten in einem video
erneut in einem video vor dem hause erst
gedemütigt dann gefoltert und
anschließend eben erschossen und ja nach
der bevölkerung sozusagen auch noch
ermordet und wir sehen uns auch einmal
an wie diese heimat dieser amerikanische
waffe also was die für zerstörungen
anrichtet von außen sieht das haus nach
halbwegs in ordnung aus aber wir sehen
hier ist die kaymers oben eingeschlagen
die ganze stockwerke sind sozusagen von
oben nach unten durch zerstört worden
mehrere stockwerke
eingestürzt und auch von außen medien
ist gleich noch mal gab es ein großer
anschlag an dem haus nämlich dort zeigen
dass man kurz hier sehen wir ein großes
loch und das ist eben nicht nur ein loch
sondern das geht dann in die stockwerke
reihen das russische offiziere russische
soldaten die hier vielleicht sich auf
weitere folterungen vorbereitet haben
wurden bei diesem angriff relativ
wahrscheinlich getötet wir sehen uns
auch an was in
sotschi passiert im norden des landes
hier sehen wir relativ gut versteckt
aber wenn man es genau hinsieht erkennt
uns doch ein flugabwehrgeschütz vom typ
dongus katongo ska ein relativ modernes
flugabwehrgeschütz der wo sich eine
armee bisschen vergleichbar mit dem
gepard hat sind schnellfeuergewehre hat
aber auch raketen an bord um auf
flugzeuge in bis zu vier kilometern zu
schießen versteckt sich hier in einer
der eingenommenen steht nur zwei
kilometer entfernt von der grenze zu
russland und wir sehen jetzt hier wie
die ukrainische armee dieses geschützt
trifft zwischen den beiden wohnhäusern
die wir eben gesehen haben auch hier
verstecken sich die russen natürlich
wieder zwischen wohnhäusern und wir
sehen hier diese heftigen explosionen
das ist also die die munition die dort
verbrennt und wir sehen die tomtom
busker nach dem angriff wie sie
ausgebrannt ist so also die ukraine die
auch versuchen weiterhin in der region
kreativ hier die russen zu besiegen und
als allerletztes wollen wir auch eine
neue amerikanische waffe ansehen
vielleicht erst mal kurz
was ist hier zu sehen wir sehen hier
russische soldaten die in einem jahr in
einem graben hocken in hessen hier zum
beispiel ein gewehr hier sind wir auch
noch ein gewehr dazwischen sitzen
tatsächlich die soldaten ja und haben
offenbar gerade keinen befehl haben
nichts zu tun sitzen in diesem wasser
kanal der im sommer leer ist und warten
auf ihre befehle und was die ukraine
aber jetzt macht ist dass sie ihn
gesehen dass gleich anhand eines falles
eine
amerikanische kamikaze drohne nutzt und
diese kamikaze drohne
fliegt hier einmal auf sie zu ist hier
umzusehen und schlägt dann hier in die
truppen ein also die ukraine versucht
sich weiterhin in allen teilen des
landes auch gegen die russische version
zu verteidigen
[Musik]